yes I'm pregnant I'm pregnant glowing
and due any day now ellie kemper gushes
to ET about her growing baby bump at the
New York premiere of the secret life of
pets on Saturday look at you you look at
the robot is a great dress for pregnancy
purposes I have to say like I would
never notice this if you're looking for
you from the back you have no idea you
might notice I'm noticing it it's harder
to sleep the new film hits theaters on
July eighth and her co-stars Ginny slate
and leg Bell adorably matched the
mom-to-be in floral dresses on the green
carpet the actress told us she's due in
august she announced she was expecting
her first child with husband michael
coleman back in april you must be the
happiest woman on earth have you wrapped
your head around that this is a reality
now and it's gonna be here in a month
absolutely not I don't know how you can
how can you anticipate what's gonna
happen we're just gonna take it one day
at a time I don't know what I'm doing
but the first time mom is preparing for
her upcoming bundle of joy with the help
of the internet there will be some down
time for me to raise this baby just have
a game in it yeah swaddle I guess you're
supposed to model is a word it bought a
bottle it up clean it change it that's
what they tell me that's another books I
just I'm like youtubing how to change a
diaper
you